sind szenen die ins tiefste mittelalter
erinnern zwei männer mit schwarz
angemalten gesichtern um ihre hälse
schlingen die an einem galgen der mob
gerückt
entstanden ist das video in herat im
westen afghanistans
der journalist bilanz schreibt auf
twitter dass die taliban dort zwei
vermeintliche diebe geteert und
anschließend durch die straßen geführt
haben seit dem rückzug der
internationalen truppen überrollen die
taliban afghanistan in windeseile im
norden westen und süden des landes hat
die terror miliz bereits große gebiete
unter ihre kontrolle gebracht innerhalb
von nur drei wochen fielen kann da und
hat zwei der größten städte des landes
die afghanische armee ergab sich
teilweise kampflos am samstag kesselten
die taliban mit masar i scharif die
nächste strategisch wichtige stadt ein
das ultimative ziel der terror kämpfer
die eroberung der hauptstadt kabul
unterdessen schicken die usa 3000
soldaten nach afghanistan um dort
zumindest den flughafen zu sichern so
sollen botschaftsangehörige und die
ehemaligen helfer der internationalen
truppen noch aus dem land gebracht
werden können
[Musik]